- Do you know what that is?
- It looks like what,
I think it's a vagina.
(upbeat music)
- Today, we are going to
talk about the female hoo-ha.
- I remember laughing and
giggling a lot in health class,
I didn't pay attention much.
- I could see that from you.
- I had to really inform
myself about vaginas
because I went through the process of
having surgery to have a vagina.
Being transgender and
actually having and going
through the process, you have
to really inform yourself
of what it should look
like, how it should work.
- I'm pretty high level when it comes
to vagina knowledge, I think.
- We went to the gynecologist together,
and I was like, well, if you want this,
you're gonna have to know about it.
- How deep, let's see.
- I think it's four to six
inches deep, undilated, maybe.
- I would have to say...
- About seven inches, possibly.
- You looked at me like I know,
and I don't know that one.
- Three, four inches.
- What do you think, people just get
like this much of your penis in there?
Do I have a shallow vagina?
- What?
- Yes!
(laughing)
- Some people have
deep-set vaginas, though.
- I think this is the cervix.
- No.
- That is the cervix.
- Here.
- I don't think so.
- Here? This general area.
- God, I don't know much
about vaginas either.
- It's within this circle.
- It's that bumpy part.
- Well, the pointer was
off, it's kinda big.
- It looks like you
could work that area out.
- It's like the muscles
that push that baby out.
Some people are unfortunate
and don't have that good of muscles,
so they have to have a
C-section or something.
- Or they have a child
with a big head, like you.
(laughing)
- Oh, yes.
- Are you gonna help
me work out my cervix?
- I guess so.
- Man, I never really
delved into one or anything,
but I know, not like sexually, but like,
far as looking into it.
- Let's see, some sort of
bacteria growth inside there
that doesn't feel good?
- I think temperature has
something to do with it.
- Fairly ugly when it comes out,
and it does smell really bad
and you can't really have sex.
- That you can cure.
- You are so good with this,
you're doing better than I thought.
- I think a vaginal discharge is when,
I have no idea, it must
discharge something.
- Would that be like when a girl's horny,
and she gets wet when she's
about to have sex or something?
- Yeah, Vaginal Discharge,
they're a pretty good hardcore
band from like the '80s.
- It's not pee, right?
Wouldn't be pee.
- Inside, comes from a
few different reasons,
I think there's certain
diseases you might have
like a yeast infection,
you can get it from that.
- If a male decides to
ejaculate inside of a female,
the vagina can push it back out, possibly?
- All vaginas have discharge.
There's healthy discharge and
there's unhealthy discharge.
- There's a lot to it.
- Yeah.
- And plus, it costs a lot.
- A vagina, it's a whole biome
inside you gotta keep clean.
- Is this how my vagina is?
- It's so easy being a dude.
- There is no one vagina,
there's a whole bunch
of variety of vaginas.
- It's such a beautiful thing to have.
The vagina's like power,
like woman power, yeah!
- Yeah, vaginas are like,
that's what's up right there.
You gotta love vaginas no matter what.
(energetic music)